welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and as the day that marvel eternals will
enter our eyeballs fast approaches we've
all been able to glean more and more
from eternal's promo material that in
the mcu's past sprite the eternal used
her mastery of illusion magic to
entertain the ancient babylonians with
stories of her and her eternal brothers
and sisters that would become the root
for several of humanity's early
mythologies so we here at new rockstars
thought it would be fun to do a little
history lesson to try to connect all of
these eternals to the real world history
that they secretly inspired in the mcu
so let's dig on in my beautiful nerd
babies and please keep in mind this
didn't happen in real life the eternals
aren't real mythology was not inspired
by the eternals but let's just pretend
it was and hey before we start i've got
to ask you guys did you ever hear the
ancient greek tragedy of doth icarus the
fool
i thought so because it's very popular
but the myth story goes that after thy
dallas and his son icarus are trapped in
this super huge and impossible maze that
daedalus built for king minos of crete
by that very king himself daedalus made
him and his dumbass son icarus wax wings
so that they could fly over and away
from the impossible base because not
even die dallas himself knew how to make
it out of that confusing ass zig zaggy
maze i bet it was a corn maze i can
never find my way out of those i was
once lost in a corn maze for several
days and i lost all my hair out of worry
however despite his father deliberately
telling him not to fly too high or low
icarus said father i believe i can fly i
believe i can touch the sky but the sun
said um
i believe you can die bish
and cooked icarus wings faster than a
kfc drive-through causing icarus to
touch the ocean instead causing daedalus
to become cry dallas
some very sad stuff it's very sad and in
the marvel comics this tragedy is
adapted in a very unique way because
icarus the eternal is actually the cry
dallas of earth-616 because fun fact
marvel has never actually revealed the
original name of the eternal icarus
because he named himself icarus after
his son icarus who died while using a
flying device that the father icarus
made for his son before he could get a
chance to teach his son how to use it
and so the eternal icarus calls himself
icarus out of guilt and remembrance for
his son leaving his original name to be
a complete mystery to this day and hey
before we continue this video is brought
to you by the ridge the ridge wallet is
light sleek and industrial and it's
designed to fit in your front pocket
unlike those bulky back pocket wallets
that we won't talk about stupid old
school wallets what are you doing the
ridge wallet holds up to 12 cards and
still has room for cash the ridge wallet
comes in over 30 styles and colors
including carbon fiber and burnt
titanium which is what i got right here
and there's even an 18 carat gold-plated
wallet which i think aisha and the other
shiny sovereign folks from guardians of
the galaxy volume 2 would probably
appreciate because they're all very gold
and i really like how strong and sturdy
the ridge wallet feels like this is not
a product that is going to bend or crack
if you sit on it weird or drop it on the
ground like literally check this out
i'm trying to bend it and it's not
happening the only thing that's going to
break is my will to break this wall
it's literally so
very sturdy and every ridge wallet comes
with a lifetime guarantee and they'll
let you test drive it for 45 days and
send it back for a full refund if you do
not love it and it's got 30 000 5 star
reviews so you'll probably love it 30
000 5 stars is like 150 000 stars that's
a lot of stars and ridge also has great
backpacks and travel bags with rfid
blocking pockets and optional device
charging batteries so get 10 off today
with free worldwide shipping and returns
by going to ridge.com new rockstars that
is ridge.com
new rockstars and be sure to use the
code new rockstars so please find the
link in the video's description and next
up we have the matter transmuting
eternal cersei who could be linked to
the real world myth of homer's the
odyssey the prequel to super mario
odyssey for the nintendo switch and
that checks out and according to the
greek myth cersei was the demigod
daughter of the sun god helios and the
ocean myth percy who had the power to
turn people into animals against their
will which is pretty uncool to pretty
much everyone that doesn't write sonic
fan fiction which included all of the
hero odysseus friends during the course
of his quest cersei turned all of his
friends into pigs just because it was
something to do how rude but not
odysseus because the greek god hermes
had odysseus protected from cersei's
magic with that good magic herb man and
because odysseus knew his way around the
ladies he actually ended up convincing
cersei to un-pickify his homies getting
her to fall in love with him and then
letting him and all of his homies live
with her for free for a year that is the
most gangster [ __ ] that i have ever
heard in my life he went from friends
who are swine to 69.
[Laughter]
and fun fact this story from homer's
odyssey is actually canon in the marvel
comics with marvel cersei hilariously
recounting how she turned olive
odysseus's friends into pigs because
they all lived like slobs in eternals
number four from 1976. but hey as long
as we're talking about eternals number
four is diseases let's talk about the
eternals number four from 2006 where we
learned that the eternal sprite actually
affected human history in her own
hilarious way by being the very
inspiration for the character of peter
pan true story well true fake story
because it didn't actually happen
because sprite was bitten by whatever
annoying bug loki was bit with sprite's
love for mischief was as eternal as her
youth and instead of helping humanity
from the shadows like her family does
she literally flew in front of the
future peter pan author james matthew
berry and did a bunch of sparkly magic
[ __ ] just to show off when she's
literally supposed to be in hiding but
hey in her defense if i could create
illusions and fly i'd be flexing that
[ __ ] too like what the [ __ ] leading
james marvin barry to realize that this
sprite had that good new sound that he
was looking for and moving on the
eternal gilgamesh is of course linked to
the ancient sumerian epic of gilgamesh
which is like the oldest ever written
story with records dating as far back as
2000 bce the story tells of an arrogant
demigod warrior named gilgamesh who
fought a bunch of mythical creatures
with his best friend enkidu before
starting on a quest to try and conquer
death after his bestie nkudu dies but
while i'm sure that mcu eternal
gilgamesh might be good in the whole
immortality department i think mcu
gilgamesh might find his kindred warrior
spirit within fina as they seem to have
a bit of a competitive relationship and
hey speaking of fina i'm sure you can
all guess that the eternal athena is
linked to the greek warrior goddess of
wisdom athena born from the very skull
of zeus himself which somehow still
seems a lot less painful than human
childbirth and with athena also being
the greek goddess of war it does make a
lot of sense for sprite's stories of
fina warrior princess to be mistaken for
a greek gut-stabbing goddess the greek
god of fire and the forge of fastest
would find his roots in the eternal's
weaponsmith fast open and fastus was
always cooking up only the finest
weapons for the eternals of olympia much
like efastos mythologically did for both
humanity and his fellow greek gods and i
have a feeling that mcu fastos will
probably be nudging humanity along with
technological tools and advancements in
a similar vein and the tales of the
eternal ajac has apparently been
mistaken for the mythological figure of
quetzalcoat but the ancient aztecs in
the comics and with ajax being the
leader of the eternal's effort to guide
humanity along the ways of agriculture
as well as protecting them from the
deviant threats mcu ajac being like
morphed into the aztec god of vegetation
is very much in line with the motherly
and healing tone that the eternals
trailer have framed around the character
and ajax in the marvel comics also finds
her roots in the ancient greek
mythological hero ajax the great who was
great at murdering his enemies and while
this isn't a greek god the eternal kingo
is most likely connected to the
babylonian god named kingu who was given
a magical tablet of destinies by his
godly god mother tiamet a tablet kingu
wore as a breastplate that gave him
great power in battle and hey since
kingo was created by the celestials i'm
very curious if tiamat the dreaming
celestial has anything to do with
kingo's powers like i wonder if tiamet
was directly involved in king's creation
i think that'd be really cool and
finally we have makari the speedster who
the ancient romans would eventually
refer to as their god of communication
and travel mercury and mercury was a
super fast running messenger for the
gods which is weird to me how mcu ajax
is the celestial communicator and not
makari but i have this feeling that this
might actually probably change i feel
like ajax will lose her celestial
communication powers by the end of this
movie and be given to makari like it
happens in the marvel comics at one
point but that is really it for all the
eternals that have really made a dent in
history like that the only eternal that
i didn't mention was the eternal druid
the only one of these 10 eternals who
hasn't made a really big shake up over
the course of human history until his
mind controlling plots and plans in the
modern day so he doesn't really make
this list unfortunately but i'm still
very curious how the eternals film will
adapt him within russian history as that
character is extremely russian in the
comics like very crushing and maybe as
natasha's father because in the comics
his name is ivan druid and natasha's
father was named ivan so who knows who
knows i don't know it could be pretty
cool but that is it for our list of
eternals in the secret real world
histories that they inspired how else do
you guys think the eternals may have
influenced the progression of humanity
let us know in the comments section
below my nerd babies please be sure to
hit up new rockstarsmerch.com so you can
find all our cool nerd inspired merch
and please be sure to follow me at
mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] but more
importantly go hit up new rockstars on
twitter and youtube and when you do on
youtube make sure to hit that
notification bell so you get
notifications whenever we upload videos
thanks again for watching and i'll see
you guys later goodbye
[Music]
you